oh yeah beautiful beautiful get a big
one of it and there you go actually yeah
just torture the [ __ ] out of it why not
next I know how to keep a low profile
thank you
what the [ __ ] is this mr. low-profile
how's your own [ __ ] business this
thing actually works
[Laughter]
what could stick your my ass 500 what
you call me that huh my lip was on your
wife [ __ ] last night why don't you just
that thing off once in a while
Ansel [ __ ] hypno me [ __ ]
get up the damn self additional photos
come in handy as gifts for Grandma and
Grandpa or as a wonderful remembers for
prongs that was God cuz I'm Jewish I
shouldn't be here
[Laughter]
somebody stick a fork in those [ __ ]
chips somebody somebody something those
yeah you do do you think you could find
something [ __ ] yeah you do you think you
could find something [ __ ] yeah
it's always something maybe something
with him in the little elf guy yourself
I just can't help but there's something
about the guy that makes me uneasy well
sure
son of [ __ ] an ass when I heard a
woman screaming yeah oh yeah and I heard
his voice saying that's right you ain't
going to Shi T right for a month and I
looked underneath the dressing-room door
and there were the red velvet Santa
pants pooling around the patent leather
black boots Merry Christmas
no he [ __ ] that woman but what can I
say she had massive calves oily [ __ ]
large women what can I say
maybe just I mean MAF up fat woman what
can I say we all have our
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]